wat houdt de kleineondernemersregeling in de kor in
het kort kun je aanvragen
op het moment
dat je 20.000 euro of minder aan omzet hebt
in een jaar dan kom je in aanmerking voor de
het is geen korting
maar een vrijstelling van je btw plicht als ondernemer
de voorwaarde om deel te mogen nemen is
je bent btw ondernemer
je hebt een eigen btw nummer
en je dient btw aangifte in
je bent als ondernemer in nederland gevestigd
of hebt hier een vaste inrichting
en je omzet is dus in een kalenderjaar
niet hoger dan 20.000 euro
in aanmerking komen zowel eenmanszaken
vofs bv's
stichtingen of verenigingen
wat betekent de kort nu concreet
je zet geen btw op je facturen
je rekent geen btw aan je klanten
en je draagt ook geen btw
af de facturen zet je dus ook geen btw
vermeld wel
dat sprake is van een vrijstelling op de factuur
bovendien hoef je eigenlijk geen facturen op te stellen
maar heb je nu zakelijke kanten
dan zullen zij dat waarschijnlijk wel van je vragen
je hebt een vrijstelling van je btw administratie
maar je hebt geen vrijstelling
voor je inkomstenbelastingadministratie
dus let daar heel even goed op
daarnaast betekent deelname aan de kort
dat je geen aangifte btw meer doet
en dat je de btw op je kosten en investeringen
dus niet mag aftrekken
kosten en investeringen neem je dus inclusief btw
op in je administratie
in principe doe je mee voor een periode van 3
jaar tussentijds beëindigen
kan alleen op het moment
dat je boven de grens van 20.000 euro komt
of dus na deze periode van 3 jaar
wat gebeurt er nu
als je tussentijds
boven deze drempel van 20.000 euro komt
vanaf het moment dat je boven de 20.000 euro komt
handel je alsof je geen gebruik meer maakt van de cor
je zet vanaf dat moment btw op je factuur
moet een btw administratie bijhouden
moeten we ook btw aangifte doen
en je moet het direct doorgeven aan de belastingdienst
je hebt tot en met 1 oktober 2023 een omzet van 19 600
je krijgt een nieuwe opdracht binnen
voor een omzet van 500
waarmee je boven de 20.000 euro komt
geef dit direct door en stel die nieuwe factuur van 500
op alsof je een btw ondernemer bent
kom je boven dit drempelbedrag
dan kun je ook de komende 3 jaar
niet meer meedoen met deze kor
dit gaat wel vanaf 2025 veranderen
de oude omzet tussen die 19.600
die laat je gewoon zo staan
want die is al helemaal afgewikkeld
dan hoef je niet alsnog btw over te gaan rekenen
welke omzet moet je meetellen
alle nederlandse omzet telt made
het is dus omzetbelasting met 21 9 of 0 procent
wat moet je doen als je je wilt aanmelden voor de kor
dan kun je je aanmelden via de website
van de belastingdienst
de belastingdienst heeft 4 weken de tijd nodig
om je aanmelding te verwerken
vervolgens wacht je
op bericht van de belastingdienst
het kan dus zijn
dat je alsnog een aangifte btw moet doen
totdat je dit bericht hebt gekregen
wacht dus ook niet te lang
met het aanmelden voor de cor
wil je bijvoorbeeld vanaf het vierde kwartaal meedoen
zorg dan dat je
vier weken voor het einde van het vorige kwartaal
dus vier weken voor 30 september je aanvraag opstuurt